make the announcement and then let him
read it Shaq
thank you big fella you got it
wow
tonight 2023 MVP from the Philadelphia
76 hey Joel lmb congratulations
and we are happy to join the MVP who is
in Boston with his Philadelphia
teammates
um Joelle I don't even know where to
start with this question and answer but
number one congratulations we're all
really happy for you how does it feel to
to have chased down this dream and now
achieve it
like you said uh myself I don't even
know where to start uh you know he's
been uh a long time coming uh you know a
lot of hard work
um you know you know I've been through a
lot uh and I'm just I'm not just talking
about basketball I'm talking about you
know everything I was alive you know my
story uh you know where I come from and
you know I got here and you know what it
took for me to be here so uh it feels
you know feels good
um you know I I don't have you know I
don't know what to say uh it's amazing
Joe schecker I don't have any questions
I just want to say congratulations I
know me and Chuck we stay on you a lot
that's because we see greatness in you
you've accomplished everything we wanted
you to do so congratulations to you your
family and your organization well
deserved brother
thank you big Fowler uh you know
appreciate it
um I still remember the conversation we
had a couple years ago I think it was
three four years ago it was actually
here in Boston we had just played Boston
then uh you know you guys were all on me
about you know I got to be dominant and
uh you know to this day I still remember
that conversation and you know that
helped a lot and I changed a lot uh when
he came to the way uh you know I want to
buy my business uh so thank you
well Joel number one congratulations man
uh well deserved well earned long time
coming my question is these guys have
given you a lot of time to rest in the
last week how proud of you are those
guys behind you closing out Brooklyn and
then winning the first game
man
um you know
first of all uh you know I thank all of
them because I couldn't have done it
without them uh you know that being you
know uh you know obviously we've been
winning a lot and you know the work that
they put in uh to put me uh and trust me
uh and put him in positions to succeed
uh has been you know amazing and I've
given up a lot for me uh so you know I'm
just thankful for you know for these
guys uh they're all behind me and I know
how much I'm thankful uh I'm thankful
for them but uh uh you know I was gonna
tell them that uh you know we gonna
celebrate for five minutes and then you
know we going back you know back to
business uh we got a serious to win uh
I'm I'm just so part of um you know
obviously winning you know yesterday uh
that was a big one and you know we got a
few more coming uh and I'm just so proud
of them uh to be able to make sure to
give me some time to you know really
allow me to still and you know get back
to myself and you know and I'll be back
and uh you know we got we got more work
to do
you know congratulations first Joelle uh
MVP of the NBA 2023 season sounds good
but I also noticed I talked to Sam
Cassell a lot you know assistant coach
Casella and there's a big comparison
with you and Hakeem Elijah won and the
one thing I noticed when Hakeem Olajuwon
won the award he wouldn't go out and
accept if we as a team that come out and
before it started you said no guys y'all
got to get in this picture so it was the
same it gave me chills to hear that as
much as we talk about that and your team
so talk about again I know you did with
Chuck how much they meant that you
needed to have them in that picture it
almost was uncomfortable if they weren't
in it
oh he means everything
um you know obviously to be able to even
qualify and then they stop a
conversations you got to be able to win
and I've always said it uh you can't win
by yourself uh you need everybody all of
them I've knitted them all year and I'm
gonna continue to need them uh like I
said that sacrifice a lot you know for
me and you know for the team uh you know
you look at someone like James uh you
know you look at the performance he had
last night I'm sure you could do it
every night but you know he understands
you know he has sometimes he has a
different role and he's given up a lot
you know to buys you know Tyrese you
know PJ you know I can go on and on and
on about you know all these guys and you
know what they've given up but uh like I
said I couldn't have done it without
them uh you know it's a team effort uh
you know it's not you know I wish you
could write it on the MVP you know uh
you know it was the Philadelphia 76ers
uh but you know that's that's what it
took and I'm just so proud of him
so Joelle you didn't really even play
basketball until you're 15 years old in
Cameroon and uh when you think back
who made it possible obviously you had
it inside of you to to take your career
to this point but who do you look at and
say boy without this guy I don't know if
this ever happens
man
um
I've been there as about two or three
people uh I would say that's definitely
more people that have helped me along
the way uh and you know if I start going
on we gonna be here all night uh but you
know you you can start with I'll see my
uncle
um because he was the one that kind of
started getting to my head when I was
16. and also to my dad said about oh you
gotta let him you know stop playing
basketball and my dad just wasn't with
it because I think he thought it was too
physical uh for me which is funny
because I like the physicality uh you
know uh but you know he was you know it
was always you know all up you know my
dad about you gotta let them try and
finally I got the chance to stop and uh
Luke came back and he had the basketball
camping came on and that's really how I
started you know going to his Camp
obviously I had just started playing
basketball and you know and I was just
talking to him earlier like there was no
way we could have known that I would
have been you know in the NBA or you
know at this level uh but you know he
gave me this opportunity to uh really
come to the U.S and be able to take
advantage of you know what I'd be given
and I'm just so thankful but like you
said uh you know the one thing that I
want people to just remember is that you
know anything is possible uh you know
for me uh you know as you know starting
playing basketball so late at 16 that's
you know that's yeah that's that's hard
um you know that's hard to make it and
uh to be able to be in this position you
know it obviously took a lot of work and
a lot of luck uh but you know I just
want people to just remember that you
know anything is possible uh no matter
what you do as long as you believe in it
and you know uh anything is gonna happen
oh and this is the absolute last thing I
promise then I'll let you go uh because
this is all about celebrating what
you've accomplished tonight but I
wouldn't be doing my job if I didn't ask
uh we're gonna see you in game two
hey I gave it a shot
I've never heard a bunch of teammates in
a room so quiet you guys go ahead and
cut loose I'm sure you'll the
celebration will continue and it's well
deserved thank you like I said we we got
five minutes uh five minutes to
celebrate and then you know we're going
back to focus on you know game two all
right enjoy big fella yeah
MVP